All right.
So yesterday was day one of the Democratic
National Convention.
I did a livestream of the entire thing.
I was commenting.
I was reading viewer comments as it was all
going on.
And I don't know how else to start other than
to say it really wasn't very good.
Now, I'll talk about what expectations are
and how it compares to expectations and to
what we would expect from Trump.
And we're going to contextualize it.
But there's no way that I could come to you
today and say I'm so inspired, inspired and
invigorated and energized by it, by what we
saw yesterday.
I sent some early tweets, like during the
first half hour, which were really quite negative.
I said, first off, quote, I could have done
without the prayer to Jesus to kick off the
DNC.
Not sure about anybody else.
And I get that everybody does it in Joe Biden's
Catholic.
And there's still a pretense about religion
in the Democratic Party.
And it's not just necessarily a pretense.
There are religious people as well.
And that that's fine.
They do the Pledge of Allegiance.
Like, it all just smelled at this point.
Like Republican lite, which maybe is the goal
and arguably is still a big part of the these
centrist elements of the Democratic Party.
So I'm not acting surprised by that.
I'm just saying it didn't really resonate
with me then sort of about 24, 22 minutes
in.
In fact, I said, someone, please talk me off
the ledge.
I want to win.
And the first 22 minutes of this DNC, I'm
scared.
Can someone tell me how great this is or something?
But, you know, then it did start to improve.
And maybe my view is skewed by the fact that
I just hate cliche packaged politics.
And that's exactly what the DNC, the Democratic
National Convention is designed to be.
It's designed to be a package culminating
with the nomination of, in this case, Joe
Biden in 2016, 26, 2012, different people
to get to the election.
And it's a package, and especially when you've
got coronavirus.
So it's not just the idea of packaging up
a candidate and a platform, but it is quite
literally a video package that has been reproduced
in combination with live segments.
You have no crowd energy.
It might be just as bad with the Republican
National Convention, and this may be just
what it is, but it felt very low energy and,
you know, they'd have an actual okay speech
and then they'd cut to music or some other
kind of interlude that didn't make sense and
took energy away.
But I want to try to really see this as not
my reaction.
You know, maybe this is the right thing.
Like, they don't need to convince me.
I'm already voting for Joe Biden.
And I actually don't even understand being
undecided at this point.
And so maybe this is about a very sort of
polished, inoffensive package meant to appeal
to the few people that might actually be unsure
about who to vote for.
Like I don't know is the point.
But given the opportunity for Democrats to
do something, knowing Republicans will also
have an opportunity to do the same thing next
week.
I'd rather have the better convention than
the worst one, no matter how much it really
matters in the end.
Now, it did keep improving during the first
two hours, during the two hours of the first
day.
I thought the best parts of the evening were
a woman named Kristen or Chiesa, whose father
died of Corona virus after voting for Donald
Trump.
She spoke really well and authentically, and
a lot of the stuff felt inauthentic.
She was really good.
And then from the big names.
Listen, Bernie was excellent.
Bernie is always just so clear and precise
with his message and the stakes.
And I liked that.
Bernie spoke specifically to his supporters
from both 2016 and 2020 and talked about the
importance of voting for Joe Biden this time
around because of the existential threat that
is Donald Trump.
Let's look at like a minute of that.
My friends, I say to you, to everyone who
supported all the candidates in the primary
and to those who may have voted for Donald
Trump in the last election, the future of
our democracy is at stake.
The future of our economy is at stake.
The future of our planet is at stake.
We must come together, defeat Donald Trump
and elect Joe Biden and Kamala Harris as our
next president and vice president.
My friends, the price of failure is just too
great to imagine.
So really nice job by Bernie Sanders.
Beautiful esthetics, by the way, also, if
you were watching, Bernie came to us from
Burlington, Vermont, with the nice wood pile
in the background.
I mean, just very, very esthetically pleasing
as well.
I'm half kidding.
I mean, it was cool.
I don't actually care about that.
But seeing the wood pile was nice.
And then Michelle Michelle Obama was was really
very good.
She closed off the night.
I thought maybe she went a bit too long, which
I was fine with.
But I could see from people in the chat that
some were starting to sort of tune out a little
bit.
But I thought she was excellent, fantastic
speaker.
And again, check out this clip from Michelle
Obama going into this idea of does my vote
even matter?
Michelle Obama making the case very strongly
that, yes, it does.
I've said before, being president doesn't
change who you are.
It reveals who you are.
Well, a presidential election can reveal who
we are two and four years ago.
Too many people chose to believe that their
votes didn't matter.
Maybe they were fed up.
Maybe they thought the outcome wouldn't be
close.
Maybe the barriers felt too steep.
Whatever the reason.
In the end, those choices sent someone to
the Oval Office who lost the national popular
vote by nearly three million votes in one
of the states that determine the outcome.
The winning margin averaged out to just two
votes per precinct, two votes.
She took that head on really, really well.
So I think maybe what I needed was like an
attitudinal adjustment.
You know, how should we be thinking about
this?
Does it matter?
As I've said before, I don't need conventions
this year.
I don't need debates this year.
But if we are having them, I would rather
Joe Biden have the better convention convention
rather than the worse one.
And we'll see how that continues tonight.
Now, Donald Trump next week is planning to
do his at the White House.
It'll have apparently more of a live feel
than the very pre produced feel that the DNC
had, at least on day one.
My guess is Trump is going to put together
some kind of in-person crowd.
That would be my my guests now with Corona
virus.
You've got to be safe.
You can't do a big thing.
Packing an arena with 20000 people would be
crazy.
My idea for the speeches for Bernie and Michelle
and Biden, etc., for those speeches, I would
have instead of doing like 30 short segments,
as they did yesterday, I would have given
the keynote people a little more time, but
made it higher energy by putting together
some small, safe mass, squaring socially distant
crowds outdoors.
I'm not saying bring.
I'm not saying do anything unsafe.
But I think we could have gotten more energy
without increasing the risk of corona virus
with some small outdoor crowds.
Bernie's crowd in Burlington.
That's fine.
Michelle's in D.C. or were, you know, wherever
they're living or at this point showing the
importance of mask wearing, showing the importance
of space.
But it would have brought a little something
Magennis say, quar that was definitely missing
yesterday.
That would have been my preference.
Nothing unsafe.
We will see how night to goes.
And I will be streaming starting about 15
minutes before the start of day two tonight
on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
And I hope that you will join me there